let's ask former senior advisor to
president trump stephen miller i have to
tell you after i read that story i read
it in the daily mail there were pictures
the video you saw there from cnn um i
couldn't sleep that night it it just
it's heartbreaking it's devastating um
but i don't understand it either steven
because i don't care if i'm starving i'm
you know shawn and i are not gonna sell
our daughters these are huge cultural
differences what do we do now that we
have brought so many of them here and
some of them are just leaving the base
by the way um as some congressmen in
wisconsin have said with without any um
any tracking of them at all
well the truth is is that the tragedy is
upon us
joe biden indiscriminately evacuated at
random afghan nationals
based on no criteria no selection
uh evaluation method of any kind totally
at random and you're right the culture
is radically different from the united
states let me make a very basic point
here why couldn't the u.s military after
20 years build the pro-american
democracy
in afghanistan it's because of that deep
chasm of cultural difference so what
kind of hubris now are we applying to
say well we can't build a democracy
there but if we bring afghanistan to the
united states well then they'll all
embrace our way of life here that's just
not how it works not in reality
that's why the right and compassionate
policy is if there are people who
legitimately and genuinely need
relocation they can be relocated to
another safe place in the middle east
for example there's millions millions of
afghan refugees over the last several
decades going back to the communist era
that have moved to pakistan
why would kenosha
and not pakistan be the destination of
choice for afghan refugees
yeah well it seems like it would also
have been cheaper to take care of these
refugees in in a third world country um
it's very expensive correct stephen to
bring them here for the price of taking
one to the united states you could
resettle 10 plus in their home country
here in the united states they will get
and this is this is
true now as a matter of law because of
the funding bill that congress passed
they will get free health care free
welfare free public housing free food
stamps for as long as they're here
and
you could help 10 times more people
again if you wanted to in their home
region so this is not about a
humanitarian mission this is about an
immigration mission that's ideologically
driven and it's time to use a word that
president trump used all the time but is
too rarely used today and that's the
word assimilation
immigration doesn't work without
assimilation and you cannot have a
large-scale pipeline of immigration from
a part of the world where women are
treated as property
and expect that entire migration flow to
suddenly become jeffersonian democrats
in america it doesn't work like that i
know the last thing that the father said
is he sold off this little nine-year-old
daughter he said don't beat her um it
was just it's just heartbreaking i hope
we can figure out something we can do
about this situation
stephen thanks for joining us tonight
thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else